another massive show of force
tens of thousands took to the streets in
the capital bogota
and around the country to mark the
eighth day of anti-government protests
the demonstrations have already forced
the government to withdraw
a controversial tax reform and are now
demanding action
against poverty rising inequality and
the police brutal response to the
protest
at least two dozen people have died and
80 are reportedly missing
the country's human rights ombudsman
blamed riot police for at least half of
the debts
we are fighting for our dead in our
struggle against the government
they are killing us we need help we're
scared to be out on the streets but
we're marching for change for a better
country
pressured by the demonstrations
president evan duke is calling for a
national dialogue
but the leaders of the protests and
opposition parties say they will not sit
down
until the president condemns the
excesses by the police
and agrees to negotiate with them
the army is responsible for the violent
repression the government needs to
condemn the abuses before we talk
we also told the government that we
don't just want to talk we need to
negotiate an emergency list of proposals
the ball is in their court in the
meantime we will continue in the streets
wednesday's rallies were preceded by
another night of clashes
30 civilians and 16 police officers were
injured in bogota
and a number of neighborhood police
posts were set on fire
in one case with officers inside
in a video president duque repeated
government allegations that criminal
gangs are behind the vandalism and
looting
and set more than 550 arrests have been
made
the extreme vandalism and urban
terrorism that we are observing is
financed and articulated by drug
trafficking mafias
as denounced by the attorney general to
confront them we have designed a joint
strategy against
vandalism at the national level there's
already yielding results
the majority of the protests have been
peaceful but the violent
incidents that have occurred and the
government refusal to recognize the
police
deadly response make the possibility of
a fruitful dialogue mute
while the country braces for more
protest and unrest
alessandra ampietti al jazeera bogota